all right
uh don't don't come up in his shoulders
so don't don't lock him don't lock him
and and that's what you I don't I don't
really care what what's happening okay
uh so you can see his arms are bent I
still have the center I still have his
Center okay so I'm not and so I don't I
don't try to get a skeletal alignment in
him and then push of course that's
something you can do okay but it's not
what we're after
uh and then also watch that as now your
task with not just staying still but to
move him that's where people get tense
they start doing like just as I was by
myself and I feel all that tension free
the same thing is here as I move okay I
shouldn't I shouldn't be
going all this kind of stuff it's very
tension free and I'm moving catch
so in the same way that if he was here
and he was pushing and you feel some
tension and I want you to release the
tension okay I want you to release the
tension same thing as you go to now
displace him you're going to feel the
tension I want you to release the
tension catch
[Music]
full
okay try it again so on this on this one
it's very tempting to see you touch me
you touch me and I go back and then in
some way I go I adapt and then go in you
see or my pelvis moves this one is in
place like right at contact
Bo so that that catch happens pre
contact right when you touch
[Music]
me it's not
this okay it's a little catch it's like
right as soon as as right as soon as you
touch I've caught it and by the time the
rest of the grip came on Boom it was
ready to project okay so
catching
different you see but also
different okay
[Music]
so okay